so i'm doing another one of these kind
of big manga lectures it takes a whole
week so this is really a continuation
of last time this is outlined for the
whole week we got to sort of
through most of the stuff on face
perception though i'll do some more
today we're right there
and we're going to go on and consider
this question of what's innate and how
do you wire up brains okay
so
first a brief recap of main points from
last time
what if anything is innate about face
perception we considered lots of
different kinds of evidence behavioral
and neural and the bottom line is maybe
not that much
right so there's a few things that are
sort of suggestive like newborns have
this bias to look at faces more than
other non-phase stimuli that are pretty
similar schematic faces versus scrambled
schematic phases and that's suggestive
but then there's the possibility that
that's just due to some very very simple
property of those stimuli namely just
having more junk on the top than the
bottom like eyes on the top and bottom
okay so what would have to be a nade in
that case would be just the simplest
possible template not even a whole face
similarly we showed that there's
actually very good discrimination of one
face from another even across viewpoint
changes in newborn
and also in monkeys that were raised
without ever
being allowed to see faces
and both of those things suggest
innate abilities
to process faces but in both cases it's
possible to argue that that ability
isn't due to face mechanisms in
particular it's due to just general
vision and shape perception
okay
third i showed you beautiful recent data
showing that the face patches in monkeys
don't develop if monkeys are reared
without ever seeing faces
okay
which also suggests that maybe not that
much is innate so all that is fine but
then there's a big wide open question
that's left
unanswered by all of that which is how
do the face areas know
to land right there in everybody
robustly that really feels like
something has to be a name
okay about the brain at least to to say
where those things should go
okay so one possibility that i'm sort of
skipping over because this whole little
universe and there isn't an answer yet
people are working on it right now
people in this building are working on
it right now but the gist of the idea um
is that um
is that there may be maybe what's innate
is some other kind of simpler
selectivity maybe like selectivity for
curve things remember how i talked about
as you go up the visual system you start
with selectivity for spots of light and
then edges well maybe up there you're
born with selectivity for curved things
or something like that that is face like
enough that somehow that leads face
selectivity to land there later it's
kind of vague because nobody really
knows but that's that's an idea
another possibility that we'll talk more
about in a moment is a possibility that
the reason your face patches land right
there is something about the long
long-range structural connectivity of
that region to the rest of the brain
makes that the right place
and so all of this is very actively
being investigated and nobody knows the
right answer here
further i just want to mention
that deep net modeling is just very
suddenly in the last year become a very
powerful way to approach these same
questions from a different angle so
with deep nets you can ask
what do you need to build into a network
to get it to produce face patches
right so that's a way of asking kind of
in principle in a network where you can
actually control everything about its
architecture and about the stimuli it
sees what are the necessary conditions
for it to produce something like face
patches
what what do you have to train it on to
get it to produce face patches and to be
able to recognize faces
and at the top level why computationally
does it make sense to have face patches
in the first place this is kind of the
biggest question lurking in the
background of this whole field i'm
describing all of these specialized
mechanisms in mind and brain but really
wouldn't it be nice to know why our
minds and brains are organized that way
rather than just that they are and
that's a really hard question and i
think there's a real hope now that
computational modeling may get us toward
an answer sometime in the next decade
maybe maybe even the next few years
okay so that's overview
i now want to go on
quite a quite a discussion about this
notion that pre-existing connectivity
may be a major constraint in wiring up
the brain
so first we need to talk about how would
you look at structural connectivity in
human brains and i haven't really talked
about this yet the main method for being
able to look at the to be for being
being able to get some sense of this in
human brains
is to use another kind of mri imaging
uses the same machine it's an mri
machine but it's going to produce
anatomical images that show us not those
nice pretty pictures of brains that
you're used to but that show us the
direction of water diffusion
okay and so the the principle is pretty
simple here is a picture of an optic
tract
right
and that what it's showing you is that
if you see an optic track is a whole
bunch of axons oriented like this
connecting
retinal ganglion cells to what
where did the retinal ganglion cell
axons land
going through the optic tract chokophile
lgn
lgm lateral geniculate nucleus of the
thalamus okay so there's that fiber
bundle but the main point for now is
that
you can see that each of those fibers
has a layer of fat around it and the
upshot of all of that is that water
likes to diffuse more in this direction
than that direction
that's the key idea of diffusion imaging
it tells you which direction water is
diffusing most
okay water is constrained by the fat
layers around those axons that myelin
and so you get diffusion more in this
direction than orthogonally to it
and so the the the details of the
physics of this kind of imaging which
i'm totally not explaining
are
such that what you get out
is a picture at each point in the brain
of what is the direction of maximum
diffusion at that point
okay and so here's a little picture of
lots of little vectors saying at this
point water wants to diffuse this way or
this way or this way or this way okay
everybody with me so far so that's you
get a whole bunch of little teeny
vectors all through the brain showing
you the orientation where water wants to
diffuse at that point
and the idea is that's telling us which
way fibers are going at that point
and we can therefore infer we can follow
these things using a method method
called tractography where we just follow
those little factors through the brain
and that's what's happened here at each
point in the brain you start at one
point and you just follow these vectors
and see where they go
does that make sort of
sense sort of intuitively i'm skipping
over lots of details but i want you to
get the gist
right okay so these beautiful pictures
you may have seen before
are diffusion tractography they show you
our best guess of the long range
connections between one part of the
brain and another based on diffusion
tractography
okay and on the theory
that you should wear your data whenever
possible
here's mine from my lab whoops i'm
tangling it here
um so
i love these things they're so beautiful
one of my postdocs who's our
tractography whiz gave me this beautiful
scarf isn't this nice and so you can see
even more clearly here that this is a
cross section through the brain in this
axis right here
and so these big
um green guys are the connections that
go from the back of the head down the
temporal lobe down the visual pathway
that we've been talking about all along
okay that was gratuitous i just thought
it was fun
okay so tractography is cool it makes
gorgeous pictures and gorgeous scarfs
um
but um
and it works really well to discover big
fiber bundles like there are lots of
parts of the brain i showed you with
that gross dissection picture last time
that they're big chunks of white matter
where lots and lots of parallel fibers
go like this and tractography works well
to find those you can really see those
very nicely with the fusion imaging
however it's not so hot for discovering
finer connections
it's better than nothing but there's a
lot of ways in which it fails okay so
for example if you have water if you
have fibers crossing in some part of the
brain like this
you'll get diffusion in this direction
in this direction and the tractography
algorithm will be finished it won't know
whether to keep going straight or
whether to turn okay so that's just one
of many reasons why diffusion
tractography is lovely and wonderful and
the best we have in in vivo brains
but it's not so great
anyway it's all we have so we use it
um okay
so we can use tractography to ask
for example is the long-range
connectivity of the fusiform face area
distinct from the long-range
connectivity of its neighbors
in other words on this idea that that
patch of cortex gets wired up to be a
face area
somehow because of the connectivity to
that region to other parts to and from
that region to other parts of the brain
then we should predict that that region
should have different connectivity than
neighboring cortex right otherwise
connectivity isn't enough of a signature
to tell us where to put a face area
i'm seeing blank looks this is not
making sense okay
just butt in and ask questions if i'm
not making sense okay so
question is do these connectivity
fingerprints predict the location of
functional regions first in adults okay
if we don't see it in adults then the
jig's up so let's start with adults
okay so the way that you can do this
is for each voxel in the brain this is a
big one so you can see it it would
actually be a couple millimeters
wouldn't show on this picture what you
do is you follow that tractography and
you say oh that went there and it goes
there and it goes there okay
and you tally
how often when you start here you land
in each of a bunch of different big
anatomical chunks of brain
that gives you a description
of the connectivity fingerprint of that
voxel how strong is its connection to
each of these other remote regions in
the brain
okay that's what i mean by a
connectivity fingerprint
so now the question is
can you use this connectivity
fingerprint
to um
to predict what the function of that
voxel is
that is is the connectivity distinctive
enough that just based on diffusion data
we could say what does that voxel do
if the fusiform face area has a whole
distinctive connectivity fingerprint
then we should be able to predict it
does this make sense
okay so that's the question
and there's a lot of math which i'll
skip i'll just give you the gist okay so
what we're trying to figure out is is
the fusiform face area distinct from its
neighbors in its long-range connectivity
that's a question
okay
and in fact it is and we can show that
again i'm skipping over some details but
here is a recently published paper that
shows you in ways that should be
familiar now this is functional mri
activation for faces versus objects
fusiform face area that's probably
occipital face area another region we'll
talk about later the face patches the
usual face patches again this is an
inflated brain so the dark bits are the
bits that used to be folded up inside a
sulcus until they were mathematically
inflated okay
so that's the standard thing we've been
looking at
this
is the prediction based on diffusion
tractography alone in the same subject
about where the face patches should be
so very very roughly what you do is you
take some other subjects
and you train them up on connectivity
fingerprints it's kind of like mvpa but
you train from diffusion data
and you try to predict face selectivity
and then you take the diffusion data
from a new subject and you predict
where that phase selectivity should be
and there's where it's predicted for the
same subject and it's pretty damn good
okay did everybody get the gist of what
i just went through
you don't need to remember every detail
the the key idea is is there a
systematic relationship between
long-range connectivity of a voxel and
its function its selectivity and this
says yes for faces
okay so that's the case for phases that
tells us that in adults those face
regions have distinct um connectivity
this is the same thing i just shrunk it
so i could fit in other stuff here is
doing the same thing for scenes
functional selectivity ppa rsc
functional selectivity for scenes
measured with functional mri
predicted functional pattern from the
same subject with just tractography
alone
okay
do you have a question
it's pretty good isn't it yeah yeah now
i was dissing diffusion you might be
thinking okay i was dissing diffusion
tractography it sucks it has all these
problems it has all these ambiguities so
how could it work so well that's a good
question i don't know the answer to that
i think in part it's because you're
predicting based on all of these
different connections so even if half of
them are wrong
you can still get some predictive power
out of it that's just my guess
okay okay so it works pretty well for
scenes and it works pretty well for body
selectivity as well functional mri
prediction from connectivity
okay
so that's cool
so that says these all have distinct
connectivity fingerprints but now these
are all this is all done in adults
and remember the way we got into this
long shaggy dog story
is to ask what these long-range
connections what role they might play in
development
remember that i said last time that most
of the long-range connections of the
brain are present at birth
so that suggests that
maybe these these connections are also
there at birth
okay
so and it suggests that maybe indeed
those connections could play a role in
development at least they're probably
there they're in a position to play that
role
if that's actually what happens
so all of this brings us
to the case
of rewired ferrets
okay what what am i talking about
they're cute aren't they
they're also very good experimental
animals to address just this question
and murganka sir in this department did
this very important
paper a while back
where he asked
whether connectivity instructs
functional development that is whether
the connectivity present at birth
uh is sufficient to determine the
function of the region that has those
connections and he did this by
manipulating connectivity okay so if you
want to ask what is the causal rule of x
you have to manipulate x right so we've
talked a lot about this in this class
function number i wonderful you see
activity you have no idea what its
causal role is until you mess with it
for example like by electrically
stimulating the brain similarly
connectivity may be present at birth and
they predict where the um we may be able
to use it to predict where the functions
land it doesn't tell us that it's
playing a causal role the way to find
out if it's playing a causal role is to
change it and see what happens and
that's what merganka sir and his
colleagues did
so they used ferrets because they're
born very prematurely
and so
what that means is you can operate on
them surgically right at birth
before they have any visual experience
they haven't opened their eyes yet and
you can turns out reroute some of the
connectivity okay so this is a diagram
of some bits that should be familiar the
retina going to the lateral geniculate
nucleus then up to v1 also true in
ferrets okay
in addition we have primary auditory
cortex that we'll talk more about in a
few weeks okay so just like v1 but for
hearing right a1
a1 also goes to another nucleus in the
thalamus this one called the medial
geniculate nucleus and then it goes from
there up through a complicated chain
eventually oh sorry it goes this way
thalamus up to a1 okay
so that's the basic
wiring
of an of a adult ferret
and so what sir and his colleagues
figured out how to do is redirect some
of those connections by surgery at birth
so this is a wiring diagram of the same
thing shown here retina lgn
this is v1 is also called 17 and here's
medial geniculate and auditory cortex
and so what they did was to
surgically knock out um
a few of these connections here
okay
in in the just born ferret pops
and what happens is if you knock out
this connection here the fibers that
start this way get re-rooted
and you end up with a ferret that's
wired up like this
the important part of this
is this rewired ferret has a connection
between their retina
and medial geniculate nucleus that goes
to primary auditory cortex so we're
taking visual input at the periphery and
wiring it up into the auditory system
and the point of all of this
is now primary auditory cortex in this
developing ferret will be getting visual
input
and so
if the input were sufficient to
determine the function of that region of
cortex
then what should we find in these
rewired ferrets what should happen
in primary what would have been primary
auditory cortex what should it do
christine
yeah it should behave like visual cortex
absolutely if everything's determined by
the inputs we change the inputs
it should behave like visual cortex well
that would be freaking crazy wouldn't it
i mean it's miles away in the brain it's
a totally different
part of brain that would be that would
be nuts
but that's what happens
it's pretty amazing this is a really
important study okay
all right
um
so
uh what you find first of all is that
primary auditory cortex in the rewired
ferrets responds to visual input
okay that's cool but you might say okay
you wired visual input in there of
course it's going to respond to visual
input so maybe that's not too school but
not too surprising
but the next part is really cool and
really surprising
remember how i said that in normal
visual cortex
in humans and monkeys and also ferrets
you get these orientation columns
now remember these are
what this shows is that as you move
across the cortex
in v1 we're now talking visual cortex
here in visual cortex in normal mammals
you get this
smooth progression of orientation
selectivity as you move across the
cortex and that's what's shown here
everybody with the program okay
so that's normal
primary visual cortex in an adult animal
what do you think
primary auditory cortex looks like in
the rewired ferrets
damn similar
so not only do you get visual responses
in what would have been auditory cortex
when you rewire it you get orientation
columns you get this really fine-grained
structure
of what everybody thought this was
something about visual cortex well this
says that visual input is sufficient to
produce orientation columns in a part of
cortex that otherwise never would have
had them
does everybody see how mind-blowing this
is
okay
so that's pretty cool but now we get to
the really cool question
when these neurons are active
does the ferret see or do they hear
okay
it's rewired it's getting input from the
retina but there's neurons in what would
have been
primary auditory cortex now responding
to visual input what does the ferret
think is going on
does he say
oh that's sight because he's learned
that visual input means that sight or
does he say
i hear something because that's auditory
cortex
right everybody in the grip of what a
cool question that is
okay and so it could go either way
there's no really no way to tell in
advance it depends on how
how you read out the information in that
piece of cortex when we do mvpa we sit
you know god-like by and we look at a
patch of brain and we decode what's in
there
but really what's happening in the brain
is some other part of the brain is
getting input and decoding and
interpreting it and so the question is
what do later parts of the brain make of
this and the answer is the later parts
of the brain learn that that's visual
information and the ferret reports
seeing stuff not hearing it
now you may be thinking how the hell do
you ask a ferret if he's seeing or
hearing
what you do is you use non-rewired parts
of the same ferrets brain
actually forget if it's the other
hemisphere or a different part of the
visual field that doesn't get rewired
but so you have gold standard where
normal vision is working and normal
hearing is working in the ferret and you
train him press this button when you see
and press this button when you hear and
it's unambiguous and then once he's
trained you stimulate those a1 neurons
and you ask him what what's going on and
he says he sees something
okay
all right so this is one of the true
classics
okay
so
this means that a1 in this case primary
auditory cortex is instructed by its
connectivity and by the experience
that comes through that connectivity to
shape its function
everybody get that
all right
so both experience and connectivity can
can determine cortical function
at least in ferrets
but yes question i have two questions so
first of all what does their d1
look like after this rewire and also can
they hear things so words
yeah absolutely okay so if you look at
the diagram
there is additional uh well actually
it's not in the diagram
but there is additional um
input
that's not shown here so they can hear
things through
maybe the other hemisphere i forget they
can't hear
and they can see because notice
that's right okay we blocked off area 17
but these guys are higher level visual
areas
so they can see both through their
non-rewired hemisphere and through some
other bypassing connections to other
parts of visual cortex
right probably both of those are going
to be affected your vision is going to
be different if you bypass v1
but there will be at least some visual
information
okay
okay so that's ferrets
again you know animals you can do
invasive studies and really do the
strong manipulation to get do a strong
test of a causal role and this is a
classic example
of course we can't rewire humans or we
could but it wouldn't be nice
but really we want to know
how does all that stuff get wired up
are these regions also is their function
determined by their connectivity present
at birth
okay
okay
and due to the experience that those
regions have
okay well
we can't do controlled rearing studies
in humans
we can't rewire their brains
but we can be clever and smart and think
of other cases
so here's an important test case
the important test case
is the case of reading
okay why reading
well one we all spend a lot of time
doing it
okay and two
humans have only been reading for a few
thousand years
and that's not long enough for natural
selection to have crafted an innately
specified circuit just for reading
so that means that if we did find a
patch of cortex that responds
selectively to visually presented words
or letters
that would suggest that for that case at
least experience was sufficient to wire
up to determine the function of that
region of cortex
okay this is all very hypothetical
everybody got the idea
okay
now notice this does not apply to
hearing words people have been hearing
words for hundreds of thousands of years
perhaps millions and so that's plenty of
time for special
purpose circuitry and that special
purpose circuitry uh exists and we'll
talk about it in a month or so
but now we're talking about the case of
visual word recognition this recent
cultural invention of humans okay so
that's why it's a special case because
we know that's too recent to be innate
and so if we find a selectivity it can't
be innate
all right
so
um that's what i just said so do we have
such a thing
well how would you how would you test
for it what would you do
joseph what would you do
you want to know if
there's um
i guess i would show them words and then
show them not words
yeah it's like like not rocket science
guys we just keep doing the same damn
thing exactly right
so
start by here's what we did we showed
people visually presented words like
that
and we showed them line drawings of
objects
okay
and when we did that we found that in
most subjects there's a tiny little
patch of the bottom of their left
hemisphere right near the zones we've
been talking about near face selective
and other regions on the bottom of the
brain but that tiny little patch
responds significantly more
to
words than pictures
okay
now we won't do this now but you can do
it as a thought experiment
what are the alternative accounts of
that activation has this shown that that
region is selectively involved in
reading
of course not there's a million
differences
between
oh come on
these and those you know how bright they
are how big they are that's a million
differences right and so to get serious
about it we have to do the same game
that we've been playing all along in
this course this is like a first whack
at it you find something now we have a
candidate but if we want to get serious
we got to test some other conditions to
see if that's really for real
okay
all right
so here's what we did in my lab when we
did this a while back so first of all
this is um this is left out data once
you find that region remember it's if
you're trying to characterize the
function of a region i talk briefly
about this a good way to do it is to run
a localizer to find that region in each
subject now we found it now we have
those voxels now we collect some new
data
that may be a lot like our localizer it
doesn't matter we collect some new data
and we look at the response okay
and that's just puts us on stronger
statistical footing okay so here is time
going this way this is something called
an event related design where you just
present a single stimulus and then
weight and another stimulus rather than
a whole bunch of them mushed together in
a block okay and then you average over
many many repetitions and so this is the
response over time it's seconds it's
really slow
to words and line drawings in that
region okay so this is just replicating
what i showed you before it's showing
you what the actual selectivity looks
like in the real data not just a
significance map
okay
why is this thing
taking six seconds to respond this is
stimulus onset out there
yes
yeah remember the signal we're looking
at is based on blood flow the neurons
all fired right here but it takes a
while to get the blood flow to change
that's why it's delayed exactly
okay
all right so what else are we going to
test well a lot you do lots of different
things we we just tried lots of things
we said okay let's have other things
that are symbols but that our subjects
can't read so we tried chinese
characters low response okay
we tried digit strings pretty low
response that's pretty remarkable
because words and digit strings are
pretty similar in how we use them and
what they look like so that's pretty
good
okay
we tried consonant strings like this
that you can't pronounce
and we got the same response
and this is important it tells us this
this region is not a word region
right
instead it's something about recognizing
letters
but for the purposes of the current
argument that's okay
it's still
something that has no basis in human
evolution and so if we find selectivity
for letters that are presumably used in
the process of reading
that must have come from experience
okay
uh what else did we do okay that's what
i just said
now
i submit that this is a pretty good
argument that that region must have been
wired up by experience
but you could niggle you could say well
there are more kind of straight edges
with the words and consonants the digits
are curvier or whatever you could make
up some story about how that isn't
necessarily
selective for letters and words and
therefore maybe it's not necessarily
wired up by experience
further
who knows maybe everybody just has that
weird selectivity in there even if they
never learn to read
okay
so it would really be nice to make a
stronger case and what we did was we
couldn't find people in cambridge who
couldn't read who didn't have other
things going on
but we could find people who
did read hebrew and we had where's my
hebrew data all right hang on okay right
so here are our non-hebrew readers
um
this is funny this is an old graph it's
not so impressive looking
um
and this is this is i forgot to switch
out our newer data um okay so we what we
found is in people who don't read hebrew
the response was lower to hebrew than
two words looks like it's almost as high
actually when we ran more subjects is
actually quite a bit lower
uh nonetheless when we ran people who
read both english and hebrew the hebrew
response is higher
and that nails the case that it's
actually
that individual's experience that
determines the selectivity of this
region it depends on what orthographies
you know if you know how to read hebrew
you get a high response if you don't you
get a lower response everybody get that
this pretty much nails the case
okay so where are we
all of this was to say
do we ever see
selectivity in the brain that can't be
innate
and i submit to you this is selectivity
in the brain that can't be innate that
has to be learned right and in fact our
data show that it depends on the
subject's experience
okay
so um
good so yes we have such a thing
it's called the visual word form area
um
now
what about this idea
that connectivity of that region is
playing a role it's in a very systematic
location
it's that little orange thing right
there
okay yes question question i'm just
trying to think through the alternative
the brain has to be shaped by experience
otherwise you would never learn anything
absolutely even if this didn't show that
difference it would just mean the
difference is something you're not
measuring absolutely absolutely
you wouldn't be able to understand the
sentence i'm saying right now without
changing your brain because by the time
you get to the end of the sentence you
need to remember what i said at the
beginning of the sentence so there's
little things
structurally wiggling around in your
brain and changing synaptics
connectivity online all the time or you
wouldn't be able to think let alone
remember absolutely so the question here
is more specific it's not whether the
chain the brain changes with experience
absolutely it does it's whether
experience can explain
these particular selectivities and where
they came from okay i'm glad you asked
that question
okay
okay so now we've just argued that the
selectivity of that little dot at least
must be due to experience it doesn't
tell us about the others but tells us
that one must be and now we're asking
uh is can its selectivity
can that can that location be determined
by the connectivity of that region
okay
so to get to that
we use diffusion tractography
and the hypothesis here is that it's
these long-range connections that
determine where those functional regions
land
okay this is me with a bunch of
functional regions in my head okay it
doesn't matter which ones we're just
asking the general question okay
and so i'm going to skip over all the
details but just give you the gist of a
recent paper that we published looking
at this we asked
we found the visual word form area
that's right down in there about there
left hemisphere
and um
we scanned kids at age eight and age
five same kids
age five then age eight here's the age
eight data
these kids have learned to read in
between the two scans
and here is the response of their visual
word form area to words
faces objects and scrambled objects nice
and selective okay just like a good
visual word form area should respond
okay so it's there by age eight
what we then do is we take the data in
the same kid across those three years
align the data and say
what were those voxels doing in that kid
at age five before they learned to read
okay this is another way of showing that
it's
experience that was necessary and boom
they were not word selective they
shouldn't be these kids hadn't learned
to read yet okay but still kind of nice
to be able to show that
all right
but now the hypothesis is
that it's the connectivity at age five
that predicts where this region is going
to land
so we use that same rigmarole that i
showed you earlier for adults where we
used just diffusion data to predict
where the functional region will arise
but we use the diffusion data from
five-year-olds
to predict where that legion would arise
when the kids were eight
and turns out you could do that you can
predict actually fine-grained individual
differences in exactly where the visual
word form area will arise at age eight
from that same kid's connectivity at age
five
okay
so does everybody see how that fits one
of the necessary conditions for this
idea that the locations where these
things land
later in development is determined by
connectivity that exists before
now our study was done in humans so we
didn't have a causal test all we could
say is it was there before and it's
sufficient but we don't know if that's
actually how it worked
that's how it is working on humans
but if you put it together with the
ferret data it's pretty suggestive
all right yeah where is it connected to
ah very good question okay i'm being
very vague connectivity
this is a long complicated issue
most likely
it's connected to language areas which
we'll talk about in a month or so
that are out on the lateral surface and
up in the frontal lobe
there are papers claiming that it's
connected to language areas
um but i'm kind of a methodological hard
ass and i don't quite believe those data
i mean i think they have a they have a
medium case but they haven't nailed it
i've tried to nail it it's hard for all
of the reasons that this method that i
was complaining about i'm complaining
about it because i'm
i'm bitter about it i want this method
to be better i want to know what those
actual structural connections are i wish
we could put you know put a seed in the
visual word form area and follow those
tracks and say not just there's enough
of a fingerprint that we can predict its
function but here are the exact
functions or the exact connections
and it's
not quite up to that task in my view
okay
it's a big bummer
i've wasted a lot of the last year
trying to get that method to work and
i'm i haven't quite given up yet but i'm
close
it's you know it's okay it's just not
good enough to answer those questions
which is
very frustrating because they're
pressing questions yeah
yeah so
um
people who are blind shouldn't have this
reason
oh very interesting question what do you
think
people are blind reed
what do you think so the connection
between here and the visual system for
the blind people goes from
like that region and touching sensors
yeah
yeah it's not obvious it's not obvious
there are several papers which i was
going to put in this lecture and i just
couldn't fit but there's several papers
that argue that tactile braille reading
in congenitally blind people activates
that same
region okay they're pretty good papers i
i sort of believe it i have you know as
i say i'm a little bit of a hard ass i'm
so i'm not 100 convinced but they're
pretty compelling and it's a very
interesting question
um
and it's a whole saga i'm gonna it's so
interesting i'm gonna try to incorporate
more of this in a later lecture because
i didn't fit it in here
yeah
and and and the idea would be
if you had to guess
what would those connections be that
drive that certainly not visual input
they're not getting visual input so it
would have to be input from language
regions or something like that that
would also be present in blind people
see what i mean
okay
all right anyway all of this just to say
that it looks like the visual word form
area is is kind of special in the human
brain because one it shows us that at
least one region gets its selectivity
from experience and two because it
develops later it gave us this
opportunity to ask if the connectivity
was present before the function
as a kind of
sort of weak test of this hypothesis
that connectivity determines function
okay
all right
boom all right so where are we this
really is a shaggy dog story lecture
okay so we started off by saying um a
lot of the basic structure of the brain
is innate
most of the neurons in your brain you
had at birth
most of the long-range connections were
present at birth they weren't yet
myelinated but they were there
we've argued that some of these
selective cortical regions appear to
depend on experience
for example the face deprived monkeys
don't have face patches
and the ferrets see the response of an
auditory cortex when their auditory
cortex has been rewired to get visual
input okay
um and further i've argued that the
visual word form area the selectivity of
that region can't be innate
and yet it arises at a consistent
location
possibly because of these long-range
connections of that region
okay
so all of this looks very experiential
aside from the structural stuff that's
present at birth
so
is kant toast right i started last
lectures kind of saying he was
you know reacting against the empiricist
saying not everything is derived from
experience we need to have a priori
conditions of cognition remember he said
space can be given prior to all actual
perceptions and so exist in the mind
a priori
and it can contain prior to all
experience principles which determine
the relations of these objects
okay so he's basically saying we have an
innate representation of space
and i've just been giving you all this
evidence for all the other cases that
it's like experience it seems to be
playing the major role
so
is it all over for kant
well actually kant was talking about
space and time primarily and we haven't
considered that yet so let's get back to
space
remember
these spatial representations that i
talked about in the rodent brain
four different kinds of neurons that are
present in adult rodents that play
wonderfully different roles in
navigation
remember there are place cells that fire
only when the rodent is in a given known
place in his environment
there are direction cells that fire only
when the rodent is oriented in a given
direction in his environment there are
border cells that fire only when the
rodent is near a border of the space
he's in like right now i have cells that
are firing because i'm next to this
border of the space that i'm in
and anna does not have any of those
cells firing because she's in the middle
of this space
um and there are grid cells that have
this amazing property of firing in a
hexagonal array of little micro placed
cells spaced evenly in a
in a hexagonal array
okay so all of this apparatus
that i talked about last time that seems
to be playing a role in your concept of
where you are where you're oriented and
the space around you
if we had to take some representation of
space that kant might have been talking
about this would be it
so is this definite
well happily all this work was done
originally in rodents all the most
detailed work was done in rodents
so we can ask that question because it's
an animal
okay all right
so
uh what the mosers and their colleagues
the the husband and wife team who got
the nobel prize in 2014 for their work
on the grid cells
and o'keeffe and their colleagues in
london who discovered place cells in the
first place two different groups
simultaneously realized what a huge big
fabulous question this was and they both
did the experiment at the same time and
they published it together at the same
time
um about four years ago and i forget
science or nature okay big event in the
field okay so they both
realized the same thing
the way rodents grow up they hang out in
a dark nest they're they're very
premature at birth and they can't really
do much they can't move around all they
can do is kind of turn their head toward
a nipple and suck milk that's kind of it
right and so there they are in the nest
in the dark their eyes don't even open
until
the end of the second week of life and
at the same time is the first time they
emerge from the nest and the first time
they have any experience
navigating any real experience of space
okay
and so we can ask which of those cells
are present the very first experience
and it turns out
that
sorry this is a little hard to see
there's a light yellow overlay this is
the window when they first open their
eyes and leave the nest between
postnatal day 12 and 14 the end of the
second week of life
and what you see is the head direction
cells are present immediately as soon as
they can first collect neurophysiology
data from these
newborn rat pups okay they're there
right away
place cells are you can get them pretty
early
and
grid cells
soon after that
okay
so this suggests that in the rodents at
least the representation of space
uh as as entailed in the properties of
these neurons
is largely a name
okay
um so just like kant said way back in
the 1700s okay everybody get this that's
pretty cool
it's a rare opportunity where you can
just take a huge big philosophical
question and boom answer it with data
yeah awesome okay
yes great sorry i'm sorry is it martin
yeah yeah sorry are you saying that it's
in eight that it's there
an eight
an eight because oh yeah okay important
point
okay we don't know before then whether
they existed they were in the nest you
can't like really do neurophysiology on
the rodents in the nest the point is
none of the relevant experience has
happened before then they haven't opened
their eyes they haven't navigated so
none of the experience that could be
relevant for navigation has happened
before right here on the very first time
that you can test it and the very first
time that they could possibly
you know be in the world seeing the
world navigating they have them
but what you point to is an important
point i mentioned this briefly last time
but it's really worth repeating
innate i guess the word innate can be
used different ways but what i mean by
innate here the relevant part of innate
to content to the big questions is
whether it's specified
at birth not whether it exists at birth
remember i gave the case of of puberty
right puberty happens way after birth
but it's not the result of experience
it's part of a genetic program it's just
gonna happen right
i mean i guess if you don't eat anything
you'll die and then it won't happen but
within broad latitude it's not the
result of experience right and so you
can have maturation on a biological
autopilot that continues independent of
experience and that's a relevant kind of
innate okay i realize i was confused
probably confusing
innate for this purpose doesn't mean
present at birth it means kind of
determined at birth essentially
independent of experience
good you really you guys are asking good
questions and it's helping me be clear
okay
okay so that's cool that says that those
cells are all uh present very early on
and presumably independent of experience
what about reorientation remember
reorientation is this cool thing that i
carried on for a long time about because
it's so interesting reorientation is
this particular aspect of the navigation
system it's been studied behaviorally in
rodents in young humans and human adults
and lots of other animals actually
and the key thing about reorientation is
this is how an animal gets their bearing
when they're disoriented and the key
finding is they use the shape of space
around them
they don't use landmarks to reorient
themselves
okay that's a key finding this is all
stuff i talked about before and the and
the evidence that animals use the shape
of space to or to reorient
is when you have shown a rodent that
there's goodies in that corner
right the left side of the short wall
essentially
and then you disorient him and put him
back in the box he goes 50 50 to those
two corners
showing that he's learned something like
the food is on the left side of the
short wall
not in words presumably but some
mental language that holds that
information
okay
okay so that's using the shape of space
for reorientation
is that ability to use the shape of
space
this is a different sense of space and
head direction cells the shape of space
around you
is that present independent of
experience
well again
we can't test that in humans
because we can't deprive humans of
experiencing the shape of space around
them was there a question no okay all
right
but we can test it in animals okay
with something called controlled rearing
okay that i've talked about before so
again
um we can't test this even in animals
it's hard to test at birth lots of
animals can't navigate very well at
birth right so we want to test them
after birth but we don't want them to
have the relevant experience because
that's what we're asking is would this
ability be there even without the
relevant experience
okay so the answer to all of this um
the way around this
is to use controlled rearing
just like sugita did with the face
deprived monkeys and just like our carl
also did with face deprived monkeys the
behavioral study
and the functional mri study but this
will be
a controlled rearing study and a
different organism
and it's pretty cute it goes like this
this is a group in italy that has a
whole lab that uses this paradigm and
it's very very powerful
so what they do is
um
they
again i just said this the whole idea is
raise an animal without the relevant
experience figure out if the ability
arises anyway okay so in this case
what they do
is okay they get fertilized eggs chicken
eggs from a local hatchery that's
conveniently near their lab okay
they bring those fertilized eggs into
the lab and put them in an incubator
and they hatch them in darkness
okay
then for the first few days you get a
nice little chicken it's in the light
here but that's just so you can see it
it's actually hatches in the darkness so
there's no visual experience
then you put them in
cages of different shapes
either a nice rectangular shape like
this that would be relevant for
reorienting
or a circular space like that that has
no geometric cues
because it's symmetrical
okay so they spend their first three
days of life in one or the other of
those containers
okay
you then in order to get a behavioral
result out of them you have to use their
natural behavior which is that they
imprint on mama bird
and you may know that imprinting is
pretty nonspecific baby birds will
imprint on nearly anything that moves so
they take a big red plastic object and
they dangle it in the middle of the cage
and little chicks follow the red object
that's mom okay that's what they do okay
um so then you can use that behavior to
test their ability
okay um and so you kind of get them in
the groove you how you show the mom and
mom disappears behind
an occluded an occluder
and then you let the kid they chick
go follow mom which the chick wants to
do so they do a few trials like that
they've imprinted they're going to
follow mom this gives us a way to ask
the chick where do you think mom is
and that gives us a way to ask
what cues are you using to reorient
even though you've been raised without
geometric information okay
all right and the thing i really love
about this
oh i guess it's on a later slide is that
after you do the whole experiment you
take one or two trials on that chick
you're done with that chick they have
the relevant experience you give them
back to the hatchery and the hatchery
does their thing so it's just like a
really nice little
symbiotic
science farming enterprise okay
okay so here's uh actually what they do
okay so here's how the reorientation
test goes
um
after this chick is raised in one of
those two environments the circular one
which with no geometric information or
the
rectangular one with geometric
information
and they've learned to you know follow
big red plastic mom
you then
put the chick in this box here the chick
is in there in this wire mesh that holds
him in there so he can't run around
he's in this rectangular space and there
are four
symmetrical occluders
in the corner okay
you then take the red object mom and
hide it behind one of the blue panels
in full view of the chick
okay
so now the chick knows where mom is
now
you bring down
an opaque cylinder
around where the chick is
okay
and while the opaque cylinder is down
you rotate the box 90 degrees
so now the chick has no way to tell you
know things are rotated i'm disoriented
and what's what how do i know what's
where to go
okay so this is reorientation in a newly
hatched chick that's been reared under
controlled conditions
okay
all right so now
once you rotate the box then you lift up
the opaque occluder
and the cage and you see where the chick
goes
okay everybody get this it's a little
bit convoluted but it's just a version
of it's a czech version of the same
reorientation task we've been talking
about all along
okay
um
all right
you do 16 trials okay and then you give
the check back to the hatchery
okay so here's what happens for chicks
that are raised in that rectangular cage
they have geometric experience during
those first three days of life
okay so it's kind of a control case
and what you find
is that when you've hid mom in a corner
that is on the right side of the short
wall
they go preferentially to the two
corners consistent with that more than
the other two corners
consistent with the idea that they can
use geometric information to reorient
themselves they're not perfect but
they're way better than chance
okay that makes sense they go to the two
corners that are consistent showing that
they can use the geometric information
but these are the chicks that were
raised with the geometric experience
what about the chicks raised in the
cylinder without geometric experience
they do the same thing
okay and this is the first time they've
experienced this testing condition is
the first time they've experienced any
space that isn't symmetrical any place
where they could possibly
use geometric information to orient and
they do it on the first trials
okay
everybody got that
so that tells us that this ability to
reorientate reorient based on the shape
of space when you're disoriented doesn't
require
um
experience with um with the geometry of
space
now you might you might be thinking well
that cylindrical cage it doesn't have
something to break the symmetry but
there's still something geometric
there's a floor there's a wall i agree
that bugged me too they did another
experiment in which they raised the
chicks in total darkness first three
days no visual experience at all
and the chicks still do that
okay so no visual experience
that's an even stronger case was there a
question percolating in here i felt like
no okay
all right
so yes the reorientation system actually
that's not well expressed the ability to
use geometry to reorient
is not based on any experience with
geometry it must be innate in the sense
of not requiring experience
okay
so
um
so go cot
right
all right
so where have we gotten to let's recap
which what's what's innate okay in the
phase system i went through this before
maybe not that much
we could quibble some of the cases are
ambiguous
but the main evidence suggests that you
know
before you posit that something's innate
it's like the the evidence you have to
have strong evidence for innateness to
argue it the default case is not an a
right it's like that's a
it's kind of an extreme claim and so the
default is not a native so right now we
don't have a strong argument that any of
the phase system is innate other than
this bias to look more at faces which as
i as i said might be a very rudimentary
template
okay
i talked about the role of connectivity
and cortical development most of those
long-range
connections are present at birth
i showed that
connectivity can causally affect
development in the case of
the rewired ferrets
i showed that category selective regions
in human adults have distinctive
connectivity
and i showed that in the visual word
form area the distinctive connectivity
is present before the function
okay
okay so that tells us that there's one
region of the brain who we that we know
the selectivity of that region can't be
innate
okay it doesn't tell us about all the
others who knows it's kind of an
existence proof they might all be
learned by experience we look at faces a
lot we look at scenes a lot we look at
bodies a lot maybe they all have the
same experiential basis
it doesn't prove it it just says maybe
okay
all right
but then i showed that for the space
system actually we do have pretty strong
evidence that
that a lot of it is innate both in that
the head direction cells are present
before any experience any visual
experience or any navigation
and i showed that the checks can
reorient based on the geometry of space
even if they've never seen space or
geometry before
okay
so bottom line
face system
who knows but no strong evidence for
for innateness visual word form area
strong evidence that it's experientially
based and space system strong evidence
that a lot of it is innate
okay
okay
all right
i've got us to hear all right now all of
this time i've been talking about
how do we wire up the system and its
you know cognitive correlates
uh in development what do you have to
build in to get a system like this in
development what what what can you get
through learning what do you have to
build in
um and so forth
but it's a different it's a related but
different question to ask
is that the only possible way it could
it could work
or are there situations where we might
have a very different kind of
organization of the brain
okay are there other possible
organizations that might develop
under different circumstances that would
still work
okay and the two relevant cases that
people have looked at
are cases of brain damage
right so if you have brain damage in
adulthood
and you lose a little piece can that
piece move over and reorganize is there
another possible organization that would
work
okay um
or what about if you have very very
different visual experience
like you're born blind
okay
then do you get the same organization or
does everything go haywire and you have
a totally different kind of
brain organization
okay all right so i'll give you a little
bit of
a little bit of data on each of those
questions
all right
so first of all can the brain reorganize
after brain damage
the main domain where people have
studied this which we haven't talked
about yet but we will in a month
um is the case of language okay so it's
just something there are lots of studies
of this people have been on to this
question for a long time in fact broca
wrote about this question 200 years ago
okay
so
the the basic findings are that if you
have damage to your language parts of
your brain in adulthood that is not good
often you'll recover a little bit of
function
but you won't get you really won't get
it back
it's just a big massive drag
there are people we will talk about in a
month when we get to the language
section
who have had massive left hemisphere
strokes that basically take out their
entire language system
okay
and it doesn't come back years after
that stroke
we'll see actually that they're
cognitively pretty normal in every other
respect it's quite amazing how much they
can do without language which is
fascinating but for present purposes the
main finding is
um brain damage and adulthood um
that takes out language functions not
good
okay not much recovery not much
reorganization
by the way there's a whole it's very
trendy in popular media to talk about oh
the brain is plastic you can rewire your
brain take this you know use a
smartphone app and rewire your brain
like mostly that stuff is just [ __ ]
right you can learn a task and you can
get better at that task no question
but you can't make yourself smarter
right you can't like rewire your whole
brain that's garbage
okay
all right
back to aphasia
okay
the story is very different for brain
damage in kids
if um if you take if you have brain
damage in the first few months of life
two language parts of the brain
as an adult your language function is
pretty good it's not quite perfect took
people a while to discover that isn't
quite perfect
but it's surprisingly good for everyday
uses you might not even notice you have
to test people on esoteric syntactic
things to discover that actually it's
not quite right but it's very good
and typically what you see if you scan
these kids is that a lot of language
function has reorganized and shifted
over to homologous regions in the right
hemisphere
okay
okay so that's better news
after age five if you have brain damage
not so good
okay so it's like there's some
critical period for when the brain is
plastic you can move language over to
the right hemisphere up until around age
five and after that you can't really
okay
all right so these consider so right
that's what i just said so these
considerations have been
um
pulled together under something called
the canard principle
and the canard principle basically says
if you're going to have brain damage
have it early
okay better not to have the brain damage
but if you have to have it have it early
okay and that's based on findings like
this
the fact that the kids who have
left hemisphere damage have much better
language function as adults than adults
who have left hammer the same kind of
left hemisphere damage
okay so that's
a reasonable summary of the language
literature
however
this finding doesn't always hold
okay
um and uh it has led others to put forth
the head principle which is sort of the
opposite the idea of the head principle
is that first of all it depends it
depends on where the damage is
it depends on when you test after brain
damage
okay
but the key kind of insight that will
make this seem more sensible if at first
you feel like it's very intuitive kids
are more plastic in all kinds of ways
right i mean
watch me using a computer that drives my
students insane i'm so slow one of my
students once i was
back when i used to actually scan
subjects one of my students was watching
me scan he's just getting more and more
impatient he finally is like it's like
watching my mother
it's like you know it's just like you
you cannot become as fluent as things at
things when you start doing it when
you're 50 right it's just what it is
we've all seen that manifest in various
ways okay so that's
generally true and that's consistent
with this canard principles you have
more flexibility
when you're younger than older which is
also why you guys should learn lots of
math and computer science now while your
brains are still good at it don't wait
until you're 40 when it's harder you
will need it no matter what field you
are in you will need it so do all of
that now
okay
but to get back to the topic at hand
what was
what was the what is the idea behind the
head principle the idea is
think about building a house
you can't build the first floor if you
haven't built the foundation
similarly you might imagine that there
are lots of aspects of cognition that
are necessary precursors for other
aspects of cognition
and if you're wiring up a whole brain
you're not going to develop those second
order ones if you don't get the first
order ones and so if you have damage
early in early in life you may have
bigger long-term consequences
really concrete kind of silly example
suppose you have damage to primary
auditory cortex at birth and you're deaf
well you're gonna have a harder time
learning language because you need to
hear to get language right i mean if you
have smart parents they'll teach you
sign language you'll be okay but you
know this is a necessary prior condition
right and so more generally it turns out
that in a lot of domains
some aspects of brain and cognition are
necessary precursors for others and in
those cases the canar principle doesn't
hold okay
okay
um blah blah blah okay now let's get
kind of all sort of in principle vague
stuff okay what about visual cortex
what about all this stuff we've been
talking about here all of these
specialized regions for different
features in different categories and you
may notice i've now added visually
presented words on there remember
visually presented not auditorily right
auditory is a whole different thing this
is c in words and letters
okay so all of this organization
um can this stuff move around if you
lose this thing can you regrow it over
there
okay
well
not really
right
as i've been talking about if you have
brain damage in adulthood you basically
lose the corresponding mental function
that's why we have all these
neuropsychological syndromes if people
could relearn and just move the function
over you wouldn't have a syndrome you
might have a transient problem as you
relearned but in fact if people get
achromatopsia can't see color vision
they're not going to get better or not
much
agnosia if they can't see shape they're
not going to get better akin atopsia
they can't see motion after a stroke in
adulthood they're not going to get
better prosopagnosia
topographic disorientation and alexia
inability to read due to a stroke
basically people don't really recover
from these things
there's a beautiful recent article
by
a german
neuroscientist who
had a stroke and couldn't read
at i don't know age 50 60 something like
that
and so made himself an experimental
subject and was just determined to
relearn to read and he did every
possible thing and he's written about
this very interestingly and there's a an
article i can put on the website if
anybody wants to read it
he basically re-taught himself to read
but he's doing it in completely
different ways from what all of you are
doing he doesn't have that bit he didn't
develop a new one of those he developed
a very different compensatory strategy
that's very slow and doesn't work
anywhere near as well as reading does
for any of us
okay
so basically in adulthood these things
can't move around
so now are we talking canard are we
talking have right so what happens
what happens if you get the damage in
childhood
well i'm raising this question because i
think it's big and deep and interesting
but there basically isn't much of an
answer to it
it's hard to answer i'll give you just a
shred of data but basically i think we
don't know the answer and i'm i'm dying
to know the answer
um
i'll give you just one one paper that's
that i know of that's relevant to this
this is a study from quite a while ago
uh it's the case of a patient who's
known in literature as adam
and adam sustained bilateral damage to
his ventral visual pathway both sides
at day one of age
okay due to a stroke actually strokes
around birth are surprisingly common
like this happens
okay
so this guy
basically lost cortex in a lot of the
regions that we've been talking about on
the bottom of the brain that do high
level vision
okay so he was tested for this study at
age 16.
now his visual acuity his ability to see
fine-grained stuff is not great and his
object recognition is not perfect but
it's not terrible either he can
recognize common objects from
photographs
and line drawings reasonably well okay
so he has some residual vision
but he can't recognize faces
at all
so he is a fan of this tv series called
baywatch
which i don't know about i don't know if
that's like anyway this study was done a
long time anyway some
some beach tv series that has the same
set of characters and he was obsessed
with this and he watched it for an hour
every day for a year and a half
and that's just relevant because it we
know that he has lots of experience
wrecking or looking at these individuals
but when tested in the lab on pictures
from baywatch he couldn't recognize any
of the major protagonists
it's just a measure of how severely
prosopagnosic he was
okay
so that suggests that when the relevant
parts of the brain
that the relevant parts are already
specified at birth and if you lose those
parts you can't just put that function
somewhere else
okay so that suggests i mean i'm not
leaning too hard on this because there's
just very little data this is the best
there is
um
so it suggests that those that at least
the general region is already specified
can anybody think about why that might
be why can't you just kind of train up
some other part of cortex say you know
as object recognition is pretty good why
can't you train up part of the object
recognition system and just say okay
learn to do phases
nobody knows the answer to this yes
it's gone completely might just be
because like throughout time like very
far back and evolution you didn't
face region
yeah
yes but still yeah i mean it's it's
clear that we you know we have it and we
probably have it for some reason and all
of that
um but why couldn't you just grow a new
one over in a different part of cortex
what's wrong with that other bit of
cortex what might it not have that you
might need chocolate the right
connection yes
i just showed you guys that they're very
distinctive connections this is all
speculation nobody knows why i'm just
saying that
one guess is that the reason these
things can't just take up residence
someplace else is they need those
particular connections
right to get the right input to process
right
okay anyway this is going way beyond the
data
but in principle people could get more
data of this kind and answer this
question if i can find the relevant
subjects i'm aiming to do this
okay so let's take one other case very
different kind of um
change to ask what happens like how so
basically bottom line of all of this is
stuff doesn't move around that much like
early brain damage to language regions
they can shift to the homologous regions
in the right hemisphere
but all the other data that i know of
suggests you can't just take anything
and move it around a few centimeters
over
at least if you have the damage in
adulthood and maybe even if you have it
pretty early
okay
all right so now we're going to say okay
might this organization nonetheless be
very different if you had very different
experience
okay so let's take the case
of congenital blindness
okay so how is the brain organized in
congenital blindness
well let's take v1
here's this big chunk of cortex back
here nice big chunk of cortex that in
all of you guys does vision
what does it do and can generally blind
people does it just sit there do the
cells die out do they just go dumb dumb
dumb and they don't do anything a lot of
cortex to waste on all of that
it turns out astonishingly
that what visual cortex does in blind
people is a whole bunch of other things
including astonishingly language
so you present a sentence to subjects
through braille or auditorily to blind
subjects in the scanner and you see
activation of v1
okay
further
you might think well okay whatever you
know just turns on it doesn't you know
it has nothing to do with anything but
tms studies v1 is right near near the
surface of the brain you can zap that
region and ask if you're disrupting
function and you can interfere with
language tasks by zapping v1 and
congenitally blind people
so it's not just activated it's doing
causal work in blind people
this is like mind-blowing i mean this is
like a
totally different
patch of cortex
okay
so yeah it's hard to think of more
different functions than low-level
vision and high-level abstract language
processing
right
so that suggests
radical possible reorganization in this
case with different experience
okay
okay what about those regions on the
bottom surface of the brain the face
place
word and body regions that we've been
talking about for so long
what do they do in blind people somebody
already asked me before maybe show
somebody over there it's my spatial code
and
and there's a lot of claims that they
have similar selectivity which i'm not
totally sure of but let me show you um
one piece of data i promised you that
there were going to be further
contradictions
in the whole saga
of the role of experience in wiring up
these regions so here's one more
contradictory piece of data
okay this is a paper that was published
just a few months ago
and the title of the paper is that the
development of visual category
selectivity that means face place body
reasons all that stuff in the ventral
visual cortex
does not require visual experience
okay
what
what what what
um okay here's what they did
they scanned pretty crazy experiment
they scanned congenitally blind subjects
while they heard sounds that were
associated with faces bodies objects and
scenes so for example they might hear
laughing chewing blowing a kiss
whistling sounds those are face related
sounds or they might hear scratching
hand clapping finger snapping barefoot
steps knuckle cracking those are body
related sounds etc so they're lying in
the scanner hearing these sounds
okay
probably cracking up
now the question is do we see
face place
body and object regions
activated from sounds and can generally
blind people listening to those
categories of sounds
and the crazy answer is kind of sort of
a little bit it's not super strong the
data are not you know mind-blowing but
let me just show you what we have okay
this is the bottom of the brain back of
the brain everybody oriented here okay
occipital lobe this is where all the
good stuff is that we've been talking
about okay
so this is now the sighted control
subjects looking at visual stimuli okay
so this is a significant slap
map p levels and so what you see is
uh phase selectivity in red object
selectivity in green
scene selectivity in
blue purple whatever that is blue okay
so that should look sort of familiar
okay faces lateral scenes medial okay
objects mmm people debatable i haven't
talked about it much because anyway
faces and seeds stuff to pay attention
to
okay um
and over here is this this map is the
same it just says never mind if that
voxel reaches statistical significance
just plot
what category that voxel responds most
to okay so you just see a big swath okay
all right
now
what do we see for sighted controls
listening to the auditory stimuli
not much reaches significance
okay if you drop the threshold way down
and look at this maybe a little bit
these are somewhat correlated but it's
lousy
okay so cited subjects listening to
those sounds not much
what do you think happens with blind
subjects listening to those sounds
well
you get face selectivity here that's
statistically significant
and if you drop the threshold and look
at the overall map you see a resemblance
of this map to the cited map the visual
map in the cited subjects and this
correlation is highly significant
so
this is totally weird it says yes
there's a similar spatial layout on the
brain
of these same selectivities in
congenitally blind subjects who never
saw those stimuli
okay
and that's the basis of their argument
that the development of visually
category selective uh selectivity
doesn't require experience
but now you may be thinking
what about that paper on face deprived
monkeys
the title of which is
seeing faces is necessary
for face domain formation namely for
face patches
so these two findings these two claims
in the titles are completely
contradictory
so we're out of time nobody knows the
answer to this it's an ongoing puzzle
there are all kinds of possibilities
they're different species there's
different kinds of tests there are many
kinds of things you could say but we're
really right on the horn of a big
conundrum in the field
and all i have to say is welcome to the
cutting edge it's a mess there okay
thank you
you